today on the matt walsh show public
health experts are calling for more
lockdowns while blaming the public for
not listening to them and causing a new
surge in chronovirus cases but maybe
these people should consider that
we aren't listening to them because they
demolish their own credibility by
supporting the blm riots in the midst of
the pandemic we'll talk about that also
five headlines
including a nurse going on cnn to bad
mouth her own dying patients
and our daily cancellation we will of
course discuss harry styles in a dress
you know we have to talk about that
on this show all that coming up but
first you know we love underdog stories
in america
um and here's one such story uh raised
in a trailer park with no clear path to
success kicked out of high school
multiple times faced with becoming a
father and his teens all the challenges
you know that many people have faced
jason waller is a definition of a true
underdog after hearing the words no and
you can't do that too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies
with his most recent venture power home
solar skyrocketing on a path to becoming
a billion dollar enterprise
so you could join waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year
um as he shares motivational tips
inspiring stories
and business building lessons from the
ground up this is someone who's been
through it he's been through the
challenges
and so you can listen to him as he
teaches you what he went through and he
can pass on those lessons to you
uh as waller will tell you there is no
elevator to success
the climb only happens one step at a
time you know one moment at a time
so let every tr uh every true underdog
podcast be the step that elevates you
uh scared money won't make money so this
is just you know this is this is america
and we love
underdog stories and that's why you need
to check out true underdog podcast
at trueunderdog.com or anywhere you get
your podcast
all right the lockdown plague is
sweeping our country yet again with
more and more states reverting back to
the policies that didn't work the first
time
the old cliche about the definition of
insanity seems to apply here of course
the lockdown policies never fully went
away in most places in the first place
but now they're being ramped up and
doubled down on
especially with the holiday season upon
us and as we're told a new surge in
cases
uh joe biden was asked yesterday what
americans should do about thanksgiving
and he echoed the entirely arbitrary 10
person limit a limit that somehow
remains the same
for all dwellings regardless of size so
here's what biden had to say
and just following up on that especially
with many states reporting
new highs in terms of the daily number
of cases
and a lot of public health officials
sounding the alarm over the holidays
would you what is your message to people
who are considering for example getting
together with their families and others
for thanksgiving would you consider
would you urge people to reconsider
their plans
well here's what i do let me tell you
what the health experts have said to me
and it's not because i'm unique and
president-elect it's because my family
they strongly urge that if in fact
we're going to have thanksgiving with
anyone
that we limited to a maximum
maximum they suggest five people maximum
10 people
socially distanced worrying mass and
people who have quarantined
so jill and i spent this morning
like many of you trying to figure out
what are we going to do for thanksgiving
how are we going to do it and we've
narrowed down which family members
and that they were tested recently
tested in 24 hours
now admittedly it does seem fun to you
know sit down with a list and decide
which of your in-laws are getting voted
off the island
but you know we don't personally plan on
doing any such thing in our house
joe biden says the experts recommend it
the
public health expert so-called but
there's a problem with the public health
experts and andrew cuomo actually in a
recent speech over the weekend
gets to the the bottom of that problem
listen
the key is to be strong and secure
enough to admit your mistakes
and admit your shortcomings don't get
defensive
denying the mistake only assures
repeating the mistake
we have made mistakes during covet i
wrote a book on the lessons to be
learned from the covet crisis
i think of covid as low tied
for america do you know how when you
stand on the beach and you look out
at the water and the tide is high
and all you see is the surface of the
water and the waves
and everything looks nice and beautiful
but you stand at the same point at low
tide
when the water goes out and the sea
bottom is revealed
and you see rocks and you see debris
and you see the ugliness that the water
was covering
covid was low tied in america
and it showed us the ugliness and flaws
deep down in our society now i have to
say i have some
conceptual problems with the low tide
analogy there that he keeps going back
to
i'm not sure if i'd call a beach at low
tide ugly
um maybe in new york it is because you
could see more of the trash in the sand
so i think this is one of those things
we have to say
speak for yourself cuomo and new york
but in any case
cuomo talks about admitting your
mistakes
and uh he's right you know that is
important you can't have
credibility if you won't admit your
mistakes the problem is that cuomo
exempts himself from that criticism the
mistake for example of
sending infected patients into nursing
homes killing thousands of elderly
people
uh that's a huge mistake but it's not a
mistake that he's willing to admit or
apologize for
so when he says admit your mistakes he
means trump trump should admit his
mistakes doesn't mean himself
and he also doesn't mean the so-called
public health experts
but the pub the public health experts
who are you know we're supposed to
listen to now as they push for lockdowns
yet again
have never admitted any mistakes have
never apologized for
what they got wrong and i don't just
mean the conflicted messaging on masks
and other measures
or the fact that we're having a second
wave at all even after following their
guidelines in the first place
it seems that the recommendations of
public health
experts are sort of unfalsifiable
because if we follow what they have to
say and the problem goes away then it
proves they were right
but if we follow it and the problem gets
worse
it also proves somehow that they were
right they can't be wrong
which is a good sign that maybe they are
but they've settled on who is to blame
um and it isn't them
it's you this is all your fault not
theirs
here is public health expert dr jeremy
faust on twitter a couple days ago he
says
scientists and medical experts are not
ruining thanksgiving
ignoring us is what achieved that
and ellie murray another so-called
expert equally smug
says experts three months ago if you
want to have a semi-normal thanksgiving
follow these simple rules
public nah seems like a hassle experts
now
in person thanksgiving is probably not a
good idea public what
how could you let it get this bad and
this is the message
it's your fault you dumb rubes you
conspiracy theorists you
science denying hicks if you would only
listen to us
everything would be okay now we'd be
living in a paradise
of course the issue here is that most
people did listen
there were lockdowns across the country
still there are heavy restrictions in
most places
most people wear masks and i say that
anecdotally from what i've noticed and
also according to the polls most people
wear them
uh people did listen to the
recommendations and the orders
if it didn't work maybe that's because
there was something wrong
with the recommendations and the orders
but there's a bigger problem here i
think you know it's one thing to simply
be wrong especially when dealing with a
novel virus
and it's one thing to adjust to new
facts as they come in
okay you know that's understandable
it's quite another thing to demonstrate
dishonesty
and as a public health official to
reveal yourself to be concerned about
politics over health
now you'd be a fool if you stopped
listening to your doctor forever because
he was wrong about one thing
but you'd be also be a fool if you still
listen to your doctor even after he's
made it obvious
that he's dishonest and doesn't really
care that much about your health
fallible people can still be trusted if
they couldn't we couldn't trust anybody
but dishonest people cannot be trusted
obviously
many of the people who want us to trust
them about kovid and lockdowns
fall into that latter category of being
dishonest now as you may recall during
the summer
pandemic still raging many businesses
closed down while you know others dealt
with strict
capacity limits and other restrictions
at that point
thousands of blm rioters swarm cities
across the country for weeks and weeks
on end mass gatherings nationwide
gatherings that involved if you remember
lots of shouting and screaming and
chanting often done in close quarters or
directly in the face of passers-by
if going to church is dangerous eating
in a restaurant is dangerous
going to the movies is dangerous
visiting your mother on thanksgiving is
dangerous
then there is no way that gathering in
an unruly mob of 5 000 people could
possibly be safe
now we could debate where on the scale
of dangerous to rate it but
it can't be actually safe especially
when
outdoor protests had already been
condemned by public health experts back
when anti-lockdown activists
were participating in them and yet these
same so-called experts
supported the blm riots remember that uh
1200 epidemiologists and disease
specialists and other supposed experts
published a letter during the height of
the riots back in i think it was june
condoning them encouraging them on the
absurd basis that white supremacy is a
bigger threat than kovid
and so it's okay to risk getting coveted
in order to combat white supremacy
by looting a cvs the letter didn't say
that exactly but that was the gist
in fact it's worse than that the signers
of the letter admitted
that there will be more infections
because of the protests
they said quote prepare for an increased
number of infections in the days
following a protest
provide increased access to testing and
care for people in the affected
communities
especially when they or their family
members put themselves at risk
by attending the protests but this was
in the context of encouraging and
celebrating the protests
they admitted that people are going to
get infected
in fact both of the experts mentioned a
moment ago who are lecturing the public
for not listening to them
expressed at the time at least tentative
approval of the blm riots
and so if you're in the public health
industry
and you're wondering why no one takes
you seriously now and then people aren't
listening while you call for more
lockdowns
this is it you torched your own
credibility
you tied it to a stake set it on fire
and danced around the flame
either mass gatherings are not as
dangerous as you claim
and that's why you supported the blm
riots or
they are as dangerous as you claim yet
you were willing to support such
dangerous activities for political
reasons or perhaps out of sheer
moral cowardice whatever the case
dishonest cowards have no right to
expect to be taken seriously
and whether you expect it or not we
don't take you seriously
we never will again and you have only
yourself to blame
for that let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so a uh south dakota er nurse was on cnn
last night
making some unflattering claims about
her dying
patients uh let's listen to some of that
even now that the hospital is being
overrun
with covert patients they come in
they're horribly ill
they're gasping for breath and yet they
don't believe
they have kovud yeah i think the hardest
thing to watch is that people
are still looking for something else and
they want a magic answer
and they don't want to believe that
covet is real and the reason i tweeted
what i did
is it wasn't one particular patient it's
just a culmination of so many people
and their last dying words are
um this can't be happening it's not real
and when they should be
spending time face timing their families
they're filled with anger and hatred and
it just made me really sad the other
night
and i just can't believe that those are
going to be their last
thoughts and words anger and hatred
towards you um you know i think it's
just
yeah a belief that it's not real and
nursing
happens to be on the receiving end of
that and that's okay we can take that
that's what you're there for
it's just in the bigger picture when you
try to reason with people of can i call
your family your kids your wife
your friend your brother and they say no
because i'm gonna be fine
and you're watching their oxygen levels
um you know maxed out on what we call
vapor therm
at 100 their oxygen level might be 75.
that's not really that compatible with
life and we know where that's gonna head
and it just makes you um sad
and mad and frustrated
and then you know that you're just gonna
come back and do it all over again
now i don't know if i really buy
everything that she just said there to
be perfectly honest with you and this
interview went on for like
five or six minutes and i i don't know
if i buy everything that
she said there um but
either way uh and i i
i rarely call for people to be fired but
i would say that this woman should be
fired because
if you're an er nurse and you're going
in bad-mouthing
your dying patients on cnn
uh there's no excuse for that i mean how
would you
if you're in south dakota and you have
to go to the hospital for whatever
reason
and this woman walks in
how are you going to feel about that you
know am i you're going to be thinking am
i going to be someone that she talks
about on cnn for her next cnn hit
so that's a problem also you know what
she's talking about uh
uh and notice that the anchor like this
this smug
half smile on her face we're talking
about people dying
and she's just got this this this smug
smile like
what idiots these are dying people
but the other thing is what she's
talking about you know
if if we trust everything that she's
saying uh let's just for the sake of
argument let's say that that's all true
she's talking about people who are in
denial right about the fact that they're
dying
well that's that's common you know i'm
not an er nurse and i haven't been
around a lot of dying people
but i have talked i have i have nurses
in my family this is a question i've
actually
asked them about you know not not
dealing not specifically about covet but
in general you're dealing with someone
who's
in their final stages of life and what
is that what is that like to
to be around that um and what i've been
told is that this is a pretty common
thing and it's not surprising to hear
that it is
it's pretty common that people are in
denial people don't like to face the
reality of what's happening it doesn't
matter if they're dying of covet or
whatever the cancer does whatever it is
uh people often are in denial about it
or they're they're hoping to the very
last moment that
america will happen uh sometimes it does
a lot most of the time it doesn't though
that's why we call it a miracle so
that's a pretty common thing
i would think and i would think she's
been around that before
yet now here she is to make a point
about covid
insulting these people on cnn i just
it's
absolutely despicable um and get ready
you know
we thought we were past this so we saw a
lot of this kind of thing
these nurses on cnn and msnbc doing this
kind of thing
bringing attention to themselves making
dubious claims
um revealing a real contempt for their
own patience
so we saw a lot of that back in like may
and june i think we're gonna stew out no
june's when the blm riot started so
after at that point that's when we
stopped hearing about it but april and
may we saw a lot of it that's going to
start up again
which also means and i know now you're
thinking oh god does that mean that
the dancing is going to start again too
i think it is
there's going to be a second wave of
dancing nurses
that's the thing i'm really terrified of
right now okay number
number two the student debt cancellation
idea was
trending online yesterday i think
because of this story here's cnn cnbc's
report
says in a recent interview senate
minority leader chuck schumer suggested
that president-elect joe biden
should issue significant student loan
forgiveness through an executive order
describing a possible fdr style agenda
uh during biden's first 100 days he said
schumer said i have a proposal with
elizabeth warren that the first 50
000 of debt be vanquished vanquished
vanquish the debt and one way to
vanquish debt is to pay it back
and you did sign on the dotted line
after all
and uh we believe that joe biden can do
that with the pen
as opposed to legislation so he could
just sign something and get rid of 50
000 of debt if you have student loan
debt that's got to be nice
schumer also mentioned policies to
address climate change wealth inequality
immigration reform criminal justice
reform
it's a big bold agenda he said my job is
to get as much of that pass to get the
votes for it which obviously is not
something i could snap my fingers and do
well he can't snap his fingers and do
that but he can but joe biden can
apparently snap his fingers
and make fifty thousand dollars of debt
go away
which which makes you wonder if you
could do that with student loan debt
what about my
mortgage what about a car loan payment
can you do that for us too
see that's that's one of the many
problems with the student
debt cancellation idea is that this is
just one
form of debt that people are dealing
with i don't i don't really see
why this should be the focus
you know if if you want to help people
financially by getting rid of debt you
just
make make the mortgages go away
but here's here's my real problem with
the with the
whole student loan cancellation idea
well many problems with it but here's
one of them
that the people who are calling for this
you know they would respond to what i
just said a second ago about how well
you signed on the dotted line
how can you be a victim of a an
agreement
that you entered into willingly and
their response would be well these kids
were taken advantage of this was
predatory
um you know these were these were these
were kids basically
they might have been 18 years old but
they're just out of high school and
they don't understand what they're doing
and they've been
lied to they've been given false hopes
and false ideas about what the future
holds and how easy it's going to be to
pay all this back
and they don't really understand that
they're going to be paying this for two
decades or what that means for them
financially
and so they're entering into this
because they think they have no choice
and the thing is i agree that's that's
true i'm i'm very sympathetic to that i
do think it's predatory
and i do think they're being taken
advantage of and i do think it's a scam
and i do think that a lot of these kids
are agreeing to this not really
understanding what they're doing
and they're agreeing to it they're
paying exorbitant amounts of money
for an education that simply is just not
worth it
not worth that kind of money but the
problem is so i can agree with that
but that means we need to be having a
conversation
about the university system
fundamentally
and the people calling for loan
cancellation they don't want to talk
about that
so what they really want to do is they
they they have
they have identified the beast which is
the university system taking advantage
of these kids
but rather than slay the beast they want
to keep feeding the beast
and so i just i can't take it seriously
until we're gonna have a conversation
about the whole
the whole absurd idea that education
should be this expensive in the first
place
and also that every single person in the
country
needs to have what 16 years of formal
education before they can get started
living an adult life it's ridiculous
it's absolutely ludicrous and until
we're we're ready to talk about that
um this situation's not going to get any
better
you make you snap your fingers and make
the loans go away
that's not going to cause the
universities to charge less for
tuition if anything it's going to have
the opposite effect
okay number three uh i want to share
this with you a tweet from camila harris
it's just
it's utterly terrifying but she says
know that joe biden and i will wake up
every single day
thinking about you and your families
this is exactly the problem
this is what the left doesn't understand
i don't we don't want that
i mean i very much doubt it first of all
i don't i don't really believe it first
of all i don't believe that you're
waking up every morning thinking about
uh what can i do for the american people
today
but even if you are that's not what we
want
we don't want you waking up every day
thinking about what you can do for us
we want basically to be left alone as
much as possible that's what most
americans want
um all right my producer sent me this
something here from
pink news the lgbt rag so we'll see how
far
we can get through this um
it says
new call of duty gives players proper
non-binary option
and the most toxic of gamers are
reacting exactly as you'd expect
the article says are you non-binary have
you always dreamt that one day you could
serve ronald reagan and join the
american military-industrial complex and
carry out war crimes
now i have dreamt i'm not non-binary but
i that is something i've dreamt about
if that sounds pretty neat to you then
now's your chance in call of duty black
ops cold war
players now have the option to in a
first for the series single player mode
choose their gender which includes a
non-binary option
it comes after early reveals of video
game in august by publisher giant
activision revealed that users
were eager to play as imperialist war
hungry killers could list their custom
characters gender as male
female or classified the move sparked a
grab bag of reaction from lgbt plus
gamers
who wondered why black ops couldn't just
provide a dedicated non-binary option
the game's creative director initially
sought to clarify during a venture beat
round table that okay i can't go on this
that's as far as i could go
i thought this was gonna a whole article
this is what people are worried about in
america now
having having non-binary options for
their video games
here's something that's more important
okay this this is news that actually
matters
a lot of headlines over the last day
because
it i mean many headlines i saw this all
over social media maybe you saw it too
because some hunters killed a moose
that has pretty colors so huge scandal
here huge outrage
this is the new york post's report it
says first nations in canada are
mourning the loss of a rare white
moose asking why anyone with a license
to hunt would choose their ghostly
spirit animal in ontario two female
moose were
found shot and left discarded along a
service road bodies intact
including a sacred white cow the
poachers had evidently
ignored the many signs warning against
killing the legally protected creatures
the uncommon white moose get their ashen
coloring from a recessive gene
are revealed similar to white bison
ravens and grizzly bears
in 2013 three hunters in nova scotia
were charged with killing a white moose
and were forced to return the animal's
pelt to the tribe
though they kept the head as a trophy
wildlife officials are asking locals to
help lead to the killer
and uh woodhouse and others in the area
including animal activists have pooled
eight thousand dollars for anyone who
can lead to the culprit so i just have
two questions here
number one why does why does the color
actually matter what what what's what's
the difference between shooting a a
moose with
one kind of fur and a moose with uh
with white color i mean we can make a
joke here about white privilege for
mooses i guess
but the other interesting thing is that
and you find this a lot on the left
you know what they tell us is that well
this is a it's a sacred moose according
to the indigenous people
and even in this new york post report
they actually just refer to it as a
sacred moose
not even like they claim it's sacred
it's sacred it's a sacred moose
that's not really sacred it's just
according to that religion it is
so interesting thing on the left where
the only religion they respect or care
about
are you know indigenous religions
if this was something about christians
upset because some sacred thing of
theirs was defiled
uh you know i don't think the left would
care i don't think we would see
headlines about that
but the moose yeah that matters
apparently
all right we're going to get to our
daily cancellation in just a second but
before we do you know it's really
important i think when you're
when you're wearing clothes you want to
look good but you also have to feel
comfortable
you want to try to go for both of those
this black friday if you're on the hunt
for men's essentials for yourself or as
a gift
the only place you need to shop is mac
weldon
right now mac weldon is offering an
exclusive all black pack which includes
a t-shirt
underwear socks inside of a packable
backpack the all-black pack comes with
uh more than 150
worth of products but on black friday
you can get them for just 98
so that's significant savings and it's
not like fake savings you get on black
friday a lot where they're
taking something that is worthless and
you don't need any way marking it down
people go and buy it this is something
you actually need you know you need
comfortable clothes
and you know me with mac welding you've
got men's essentials like socks
shirts hoodies underwear polos active
shorts uh mac welding promises comfort
and a consistent fit
plus they have versatility so you can
look great you can feel great from
working out going out you want to go on
a date whatever it is
you're doing in your life mack weldon
has something for your everyday life
and there's also technology in the
clothes wide range of customized fabrics
that can keep up with you
no matter what your day looks like
they've also got i should tell you about
weldon blue it's a
totally free loyalty program level one
gets you free shipping for life
once you reach level two um by spending
200
you get 20 off every order for the next
year so that's a hell of a deal there uh
look once the saying here is once you go
mac you don't go back
that's actually once you go mack welding
you don't go back but i think i think
take the welding out it sounds better
so to grab your exclusive all black pack
for just 98
uh while supplies last visit
macweldon.com
walsh enter promo code walsh you'll also
get 20 off your first order that's
macweldon.com
walls promo code walls for 20 off and
the all black pack
for 98 mack weldon reinventing
men's basics let's get to our daily
cancellation
for today's daily cancellation uh we
begin with vogue magazine's latest issue
which features harry
styles in a dress the lengthy profile
styles
uh has many more photos of the man in an
array of skirts dresses
other frilly assortments we're told by
various interview subjects that styles
is cross-dressing represents quote
the image of a new era of the way that a
man can look
and that the pop star is quote
redefining what it can mean to be a man
with confidence
it is revolutionary quote unquote to see
someone who is so quote in touch with
his feminine side
now the actress olivia wilde uh in the
uh
profile as she goes further she says i
hope that this brand of confidence as a
male
that harry has truly devoid of any
traces of toxic masculinity
is indicative of his generation
therefore the future of the world
she says about a guy wearing a blouse i
think he's in many ways championing that
spearheading that it's pretty powerful
and kind of extraordinary to see someone
in his position
redefining what it can mean to be a man
with confidence
now not everyone is a fan of this
supposed
revolution of men wearing dresses you
can count me in the
not everyone camp also candace owens
whose tweet on the subject sparked a
massive online backlash
she wrote in response to the vogue piece
she says there is no society that could
survive without strong men the east
knows this in the west the steady
feminization of our men
at the same time that marxism is being
taught to our children is not a
coincidence
it is an outright attack bring back
manly men she says now the counter
arguments to owens myself ben shapiro
who was also trending yesterday for
committing the crime of agreeing with
candace owens
the counter arguments to us and anyone
else who questions whether we should be
redefining what it can mean to be a man
in this way
mostly have revolved around the theme
that uh we're making too big a deal out
of it and it's weird that we care so
much
and seriously it's just a dude in a
dress what's the big deal
this is the tried and true leftist
culture war tactic
and we have to really realize what
they're doing because it never changes
we've seen the same play countless times
already
they mocked the other side for
supposedly making a big deal out of the
very thing
they were just insisting is a big deal
they throw a parade to celebrate some
ridiculous thing or another
and then they insist that any random
straggler who declines to join them
is a hysterical weirdo who sins somehow
is caring too much about it
they're the ones throwing the parade all
we're saying is uh you know i'd rather
not
and they say what do you care so much
about what are you making such a big
deal out of this
they present one side of the argument
and hope to win the dispute by
convincing you
that only a freakish loser would bother
presenting the other side
they try and often succeed in dressing
something up as
both a revolutionary world-changing act
and a totally banal normal everyday
occurrence that should barely attract
notice
they shout uh why are you looking over
here right after they just shouted hey
look over here
people who have good arguments don't
bother with mind games and these are
mind games
in reality the fact that harry styles
himself wears dresses
is indeed banal and uninteresting you
know i would not have elected to publish
a 5 000 word cover story on the subject
but that was vogue's choice not mine
there is nothing particularly
revolutionary or earth-shattering about
a pop star dressing in silly outfits pop
stars have been doing that since the
dawn of the genre
but the overall attempt by our culture
to redefine masculinity and feminize men
is important and it is certainly worth
fighting against
different times and places have had
slightly different ideas about how men
and women ought to look
and act but none have ever declared
that men and women are the same and
ought to look the same way and do the
same things
that is our unique innovation and the
results have already been catastrophic
in our culture
a society without a clear idea of what a
man is or what a woman is
um and and what a man does is a society
that breeds despair individually and
decay collectively and we're witnessing
that right now
it's not that one cross-dressing dude
can have this effect
there have been cross-dressing dudes
since time immemorial as many on the
left have
correctly pointed out the difference
is that cross-dressing in times past
was seen as bizarre different
usually done for a laugh masculinity
itself was not threatened by it because
society's
recognition of masculinity and its
respect for its boundaries
is what made the spectacle of a guy in a
dress funny in the first place
so in the same way you know a guy
belching at the dinner table
might be funny depending on your sense
of humor but it doesn't threaten to
destroy the rules of etiquette
unless we all start pretending that
there are no rules to destroy in the
first place
then you'll end up with a lot more
people burping at the dinner table and
none of it will be funny anymore
the thing that makes it funny is that it
violates the rules
the point is that there's a clear
difference between merely crossing a
boundary
you know for a laugh to make a point to
be a jerk to get attention whatever
and erasing the boundary entirely
so when the left is not doing its oh
shucks what's the big deal folks routine
it will freely admit that it's that it
is reaching for the latter goal to erase
the boundaries of masculinity
and create a post-gender society where
the words man and woman have no meaning
now it can never actually succeed in
this task because it's fighting against
biological realities which can never be
fully superseded
but it can settle for making people
disoriented
especially children it can create an
environment
where boys are made to be more feminine
girls more masculine
and neither has any idea who they really
are confusion
is the ultimate objective and the left
will celebrate
anybody who contributes to it in
whatever small way
and so harry styles is canceled yes but
more so i'm cancelling everyone who
wants to
revolutionize masculinity and yet
refuses to at least be honest about what
they're doing and by the way
even if stiles didn't wear a dress at
all i'd still cancel him for this
picture right here
uh this was also in the in the vogue
spread
that's a kilt he's wearing not a skirt
so that's fine he gets by on the
technicality here
but he's also jumping on a trampoline um
men should never be photographed jumping
on trampolines
especially when they're wearing kilts
and especially because they had to bring
this trampoline out to this field
in order for him to jump on it they
brought they brought a trampoline out
into a
field of flowers put them in a kilt and
had him jump on it and took pictures
the whole thing is terribly undignified
um even more so than the dresses in my
view so
that's that's cancelled too everybody's
cancelled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there